All right, let's be honest how many dog get up and you just get your day started
You don't have it written down. You won't have a strategy you don't have a real plan
You kind of just get up and say I'm about to tackle today raise your hand for me raise your hand
we're gonna stop no more that there is one habit that I have adopted in the last three years that has
Fundamentally changed me as a business person
I went for ten years with an average of five to six hours of sleep
I felt like it was genetic and I felt like I had a ton of energy
until something happened
What's up belief nation, it's Evan. My one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level talent at something and I want you to
Find it embrace it and use it to make a difference now
I started to believe life series to try to tackle different topics outside of just straight-up pure entrepreneurship
So to help you live your best believe life today. We're gonna look at five morning routines that can help transform your life
enjoy
Alright, let's kick it off with routine number one stick with our routine with Eric Thomas
All right. Let's be honest how many y'all get up and you just get your day started?
You don't have it written down. You won't have a strategy you don't have a real plan
You kind of just get up and say I'm about to tackle today raise your hand for me raise your hand
We're gonna stop no more that like you don't go to war without a plan
You just don't come out just digit that. I hope I hit somebody
I told you I win on that Arnold Schwarzenegger stuff. That is it. I'll be back. This would be blue
He's just blowing up stuff. We own that Jason Bourne
You're going to the top floor
That we got the scope
I'm being 100. We know he just gets up in the woods by 8 somebody in the kitchen
You just tore up the whole house. I
Mean you got my man with you to throw the whole house up
Got some other people in the mending process you mean he barely got here me together better than uh strategy open up
So pop you later or a couple hours
Mission accomplished you move on I need you to be strategic
I hear looking I want to go to the NBA not like that. You just running up and down the court not like that
You're not going
No strategy. I want to go through there fail. You ain't even in school. No, you're not going to the NFL
I want to make millions you're not even doing what millionaires do and that those of you you messed up
Why because you're not you don't understand think act eat rest. So what are we talking about?
We're talking about a schedule. I realized that my strength is in my routine
Why?
Because I'm not as strong as I thought I was I'm not as intelligent as I thought I was I don't want it as bad
As I thought I wanted it. It's my routine. It's what I do every day
Repeatedly, I just help somebody out you're struggling because you don't have a routine you all
You finally got my man I have to pull out that but you messed up everything else in your life
You lost all your friends cuz you do have a schedule the DNA of your success is in your routine
You're not as deep as you think you are. You gotta find a routine. I'm getting up at 3:00 and stick with it
I'm getting up at 5:00 and stick with it. Yeah out of 365 days
You have a bad day or two
But I'm trying to tell you the strength is in the routine find a routine and stick with it
Routine number two get rid of your phone with Mel Robbins. So other than the five-second rule
There is one habit that I have
Adopted in the last three years that has fundamentally changed me as a business person and it has also changed
My ability to manage my emotions so I don't get hijacked. I do not allow
my phone in the bedrooms, I
know the research
The light just did a study based on phone use alone and 33 percent
Of people are reading emails in the middle of the night
I know that if you go to bed and the phone is right next to you
Right, so you go to bed because you need your phone. You know, somebody might need you and you sleep
You know if this is right here and it's not closed and the blue light is on they've done studies where you have people at
A table and the researcher will put their phone on the table
not even my phone the researchers phone and the brain lights up like crazy just with the presence of a phone the
Research around the phone and sleep is so stunning that if you were to adopt one radical thing today
Other than the five-second rule try putting your phone outside your bedroom turn off the blue
So you don't hear it tell people who need to reach you to call you my kids
I have a kid in college a kid who's you know high school kid in middle school if there's an emergency. Call me
There is nothing happening on your phone at two o'clock in the morning. That's important
but if you allow yourself to become a tool of this
This is supposed to be your tool for selling your tool for communicating and we're all becoming the tool
Here's the other thing common sense. Why's that? I want you to understand you wake up the alarm goes off
What do you do?
So you're not even
vertical and you're reading emails and
What is in these emails other people's crap if you don't have boundaries with this puppy?
it's gonna effect sleep. it's gonna
When I put this thing outside the bedroom and
I wake up I walk over to where the phone is it plugged into my bathroom. I turn it off
I don't look at again
I give myself five minutes five minutes before I tune into the world to actually tune in up here to say
What's the one thing I'm gonna get done today that really matters to me
If you're the kind of person that feels like you don't have control over your day that your day gets hijacked that you can't get
To the priorities that you're always behind the ball this one planning thing will change your life
No phone in the bedroom. Turn it off when the alarm goes off five minutes five lousy minutes
Five thousand minutes before you tune in to the rest of the world
And if you've got the kind of job where you've got to check it get up ten minutes earlier
You have control over this stuff and it is so important that you take it seriously
Now because you're living at the slowest moment of your entire life
Routine number three get more sleep with Chase Jarvis I went for ten years
with an average of five to six hours of sleep
I felt like it was genetic and I felt like I had a ton of energy
Until something happened and that thing that happened was I was totally crushed about two years ago
I'd been burning into both ends working 20 hours a day not getting any sleep
I went to Hawaii and I say, you know
I'm just gonna like I'm gonna have zero schedule on vacation ice left fort hours a day
for like six days straight and I felt
Completely different than I had for the previous like six eight weeks that I've been burning at both ends now
Starting about a year ago
I showed it tracking my sleep and I aim to stay in bed for eight hours a day
I can tell you that I am a
Definitively way smarter way nicer more in touch with my creative side way more in touch with my intellect
And I'm just a better human when I have more sleep routine number four
Schedule everything with Daymond John
My morning routine five years ago was I would get up and I would look at my emails a couple of them
I wouldn't let them consume me because I'm Dyslexic and I know that when you read it takes more of the brain to utilize to
Read it so I would use it to stimulate my brain right? I'll get up. I'd read my goals
like I've always done and
I would try to eat something healthy and then I would get to the office because I was like
I can't work out too early because number one there's a lot of fires. I need to put out and I can't do that
as I started to
Realize what was going on. I started do these interviews with people I started saying, all right
May I need to change this around so now it's totally different. So I'll get up. I'll do my goals
I will still do that small part of reading the
Email but I will not look at social media
which I used to and
now I'll go work out because I used to work out at night when I felt that my emails weren't coming in that much and
I wanted to kind of get tired so I rested but I start working out now early
earlier in the day and and I start also scheduling time with my daughter and with my family to make sure that that is
Priority over anything else and I also schedule any kind of health things
I need to do doctors checkups physicals whatever the case is what that did was
I'm more productive because the adrenaline running and I got to work and I'm I'm
I'm more active. I didn't eat the egg and cheese sandwich was slowing me down
Right, and I need to chill out for a little while. I started doing my
Spending more time with my family and because I started say I'm gonna make a major
Appointment any kind of point when I can once a month for my health I end up finding out I had stage 2 cancer
After reading after son to find out all you know
All these people's techniques because I look further into my health
And I end up finding out ahead stay true cancer and it didn't say my life necessary cuz I had thyroid cancer which would still
Be a challenge, but I had a surgery and I got the cancer I'm old
I'm cancer-free, you know
and it was because of
me
altering my life with these small adjustments a new tee number five the last one before a very special bonus clip for you is
Win the morning win the day with Tim Ferriss?
One of the commonalities one of the patterns that you spot really quickly if you interview hundreds of world-class performers, and I just interviewed
130 or so for my new book tribal mentors is
the fact that they have consistent morning routines
they have some type of recipe a boot up sequence that they use to win the day in some fashion and it ranges from
for instance
Mindfulness and that could be mindfulness meditation
Where you find say Evan Williams who is well known for a blogger Twitter
also medium who spends time every morning as I do with some type of meditative practice could be
Insight it could be a trans dental meditation
You could use an app like headspace which I think is a great place to start and it trains you it allows you to practice
Becoming more aware and less reactive so that you're not thrown off by the unexpected
Challenges and problems of the day and that helps you to be much more productive and much more centered
You can achieve that in other ways
Gratitude is a common element. So Tim O'Reilly who's just an incredible entrepreneur thinker writer and
Thought leader in Silicon Valley goes for a run and
Will take a photograph of a single flower on his run every morning, right and this teaches you to pause
To pause and to assess how your say responding to things
So that is a really beautiful practice that can be done with gratitude lists
I use something called the 5-minute journal
but Whitney Cummings incredible stand-up comedian writer and much more also has
Gratitude lists and this is say naming three things that you're grateful for. Each morning. Tony robbins. Does this Brian Grazer?
Incredibly well known
iconic TV and film producer also, does this I think he's had one hundred and Emmy nominations or something like that and
that achieves very much the same thing of present state awareness and looking for the positive as opposed to fixating on the negative and
Last but not least you have say Jocko willing retired Navy SEAL commander
who will lay out his clothing his workout clothing the night before so that
There's no conscious decision required were
Willpower or lack thereof could intercede his clothing is ready
He's already set his to-do list for the next day wakes up at he wakes up at 4:30
that's not quite when I wake up and
Grabs the clothes boom directly to the gym and he has a home gym where he does his workout
This is also very common where people recognize
These very busy very driven people that if it's inconvenient to work out, they probably won't do it
so Jocko has home gym where barbell plates squat rack 3 sets of rings at different heights a
Kettlebell and you're good to go. That's all you need. So there's a few of the things that I've seen repeatedly in different forms with
Hundreds of top performers that they use to win the morning so they can win the day
Now I've got a special bonus clip from Mel Robbins on how to develop a great morning routine
But before that I want to know what did you take from this video what lesson you're gonna apply immediately
To your morning routine. What was the most impactful clip? Let me know in the comments below when you write something down
It's also much more likely to stick for yourself. So you've got a commitment you want to make put it in the comments
Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever. Your one word is much. Love see you soon, and enjoy the bonus clip
You must come up with a morning routine
That you do
every single morning or at least more mornings than not that
Puts you in control of yourself and in control of your day
this is what I do and
I cannot explain the power that I get
From starting my day off and being bigger than my excuses and being in control
first and foremost
Wake up on time when that alarm goes off get your butt out of bed. 5 4 3 2 1 go
why is that important for persistence the reason why is because the first decision that you're making of the day is to actually
Get up and get moving. That means you are
persistently
Bigger than your excuses you are persistently bigger than feeling lazy and you are
Persistently beating the feelings that typically stop you
The second thing that I want you to do before you look at your email before you answer your phone
before you start
Surfing box advice and BuzzFeed and you know team stream and checking out the sales on Zappos and looking at your Facebook newsfeed
Before you pick up the damn phone
Please please please
Figure out your two priorities for the day
these are the things that matter to you whether it's saving money and and making sure you're focused on that or
Showing up at work and being a contributor or whether it's changing
How you treat your spouse or your kids or the person that you're with her heck getting to the gym because you said you would
Whatever it is that your two priorities are
put them in your head before you pick up the phone why the reason why is because of
Persistence the reason why is because I want you to have a good day. Do you know what makes for a bad day?
What makes for a bad day is?
snoozing
Starting your day off late starting your day off tired starting your day off by mainlining
Everybody else's newsfeed on social media and looking at everybody else's life and and saying to yourself
Oh my god, they're on vacation or gosh. They look so great or your friends are so fancy or my gosh
They've got so money you start off your day looking at that sh*t
You're never gonna have a good day. You got to start off your day by getting up on time
Figuring out your priorities and then getting to work on them. Do not pick up your phone until you have done those two things
I think the single biggest
Reason why people have bad days is because they start them off by looking around at everybody else and seeing what they're doing
instead of having the focus and the discipline
To actually start your day off with you in control and with your priorities front and center
So you want a bonus rad exercise every day? That's right
Get up on time figure out your pre-trip priorities and exercise you do those three things. You'll be kicking ass every single day
The most important work ever if you had to think of one word
That's most important to you. That sums you Apple. So it would be like a little beacon
Pay believe nation if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins, Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz. I have a very special secret video for you check the description for details